so on the 30th of October what movie
should i review hmm the crow so you know
those movies that you see back in the
day and you remember them being awesome
and then you see them now and though
they suck yeah this is not one of those
movies so Brandon Lee plays Eric Draven
a musician who's engaged to a really hot
girl you musicians taken all the chicks
and did a group of douchebags break into
their place
kill him and beat and rape her to death
but as the legend goes if the condition
of your death is bad enough a crow will
bring your soul back to earth to right
the wrongs which is pretty much God
given the green light for some sweet-ass
vengeance and a sweet-ass movie thanks
big man love the crow now when watching
this movie you really want nothing more
than to see the gang who killed Draven
and his fiancee to meet certain and
utter death they are pretty much a
collection of the scummiest [ __ ]
ever put on screen donning names like
Tintin funboy t-bird and skank
yeah real champs and Brandon Lee just
goes down the line and picks them off
now the tone in this movie is goth for
sure I don't think there's a scene shot
in the daytime from maybe one scene but
that's it but in reality I wouldn't have
the tone any other way in fact the tone
has been done in other ways and it's
called the shitty crow sequels
now what I really liked about the crow
is Brendan Lee's character I mean he's
tragic and he's sarcastic and kind of
crazy I mean come on if that guy came
after you you wouldn't [ __ ] yourself I
would [ __ ] myself he is here simply for
vengeance nothing else not to start a
new life that to send him to court he
gets a couple of allies like that girl
with the raspy voice that does all the
voiceovers and Winston from Ghostbusters
but in reality it's all about the
vengeance now the crow really does not
take that long to get into I mean in the
first 15 to 20 minutes your first
scumbag dies that is getting to the
point right there I mean it's a good
revenge movie to watch for some
enjoyment but also the movie just nails
the tragedy of it all and that's a tough
mark for a movie to hit I mean usually
they don't do that not this well anyway
do not watch any of the piece of [ __ ]
sequels that came after the crow they do
not exist I mean that doesn't mean I
won't watch one to review it I mean that
could be fun but for your guys's sake
don't watch up the crowd with Brendan
Lee that is it period now I heard they
want to reboot the crow and usually with
older movies I'm really interested to
see where reboots can take it whatnot
but with the crowed I just really don't
think it's necessary
it'd be like rebooting Jurassic Park or
some [ __ ] I mean just just don't do it
don't touch it so I would say check out
the crow it's easily
my favorite classic movie that I
reviewed so far of the five because the
crow is awesome tacular and if Hot Topic
just pisses you off I mean just the
sight of it I mean you might not like
the crow however if you don't watch it
because of that I think you're gonna be
missing out on a badass movie yeah bad
ass and just to let you guys know it
won't be able to review a movie tomorrow
on Halloween Day of all days I mean
would it make sense to review the movie
Halloween on Halloween Day a million
times yes but I just don't have the time
and I'm really sorry about that but I
will review AMC's The Walking Dead for
you I just might not get it to you till
Monday and thank you for suggesting all
the classic movies I mean we got more to
review so keep them coming and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]